[Music]
what
up myties out
mean whoever been discouraged World is
Yours hold on to your dreams till they
come true don't let them tell you what
you can or can't do I know it's hard
trying to make it on your own too
surviving at the same time going to
school and trying to pay tuition by
washing dishes it's all a part of being
self-sufficient look for a shooting star
and you keep on wishing who's to say 5
years from now well you'll end up CEO of
your own business or a movie star in a
world winner got go for it can't be
timid nah live out pH disguise the limit
understand everything began with a
vision some hard work and the thing
called intuition that's when you feel
you at the lowest and you about to
collapse and let you know you on the
right track
sing World World is Yours World is
Yours world
you can aim for the Stars you can climb
you can
[Music]
C Sky the LI SK the limit hey world
world The World is Yours world is yours
I know it might sound a little bit like
preaching but ain't a star in the sky
that ain't worth pring already done
caught a few and through some back I
shook them up in my fist and threw them
out like craps unseen some fools shoot
them up like crack and then I watched as
they store faded out like can you find
it inside of you gift that God provided
you when read the little note he left
and says the things you got to do to
make your life a healthy example of his
Perfection ease with the breeze don't
fight life Direction it's going to be
some ups and downs it's no question but
the hard times you make it through teach
the best
lessons SK the limit SK the
[Music]
limit World is Yours World is
Yours
the old The Young and the new were
[Music]
always
World hey young
World The World is Yours the world is
yours